you
you
Kyle thank you for your question the
strangest thing a role has ever required
me to do is to not like Hugh Jackman
that is that is a very strange thing for
me to do because he is a just an
incredibly likable guy so that's the
strangest thing so far
April thank you for your question the
process of acting is I think of an odd
one and an extraordinary one
simultaneously so there are times where
roles stay with me for months
and there are times when roles sort of
just are permanent in a weird way that
they stay with you forever because the
role is not just the character you play
but the people you work with and those
relationships can last over a lifetime
or you know only for the period of the
production but yeah there are scenes
that stay with me that are visceral and
ultimately this is this is my life's
work this is what I do so I carry with
me all of those roles all the time in in
an odd way and when anybody comes up to
me and they say oh hey I sign this movie
or that movie and oh I liked you in the
movie or I didn't like you know movie or
whatever they might say you know brings
you back to that experience and you can
never really shake it
Morgan thank you for your question I
think the they're probably two things
that have been most important one is
that making films is a director's medium
and that as an actor you really are in
their hands and that a relationship with
the director how much you give to them
how much you prepare for the role and
how much you help them tell their
stories what it's all about I think in a
world where actors seem to get a lot of
attention because it's your face up
there ultimately it's the directors
movie and servicing that vision is the
most important thing it's something I've
learned over the years and I've learned
to really respect and it gets me very
excited to know that when I'm working
with the director I deeply respect that
I will give them everything I can for
them to make the best possible movie
they can
you